مرحبا بكم في موجز الامباء من قناه
الجزيره اصيب الشبان فلسطينيا خلال
مواجهات بين مجموعات المقاومه الفلسطينيه
وقوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي ثقتحامها بلده
قباطيه جنوب جنين بالضفه الغربيه فجر
اليوم
واعتقلت قوات الاحتلال الاسير المحرر
محمود نزال من منزل عائلته في البلده من
جانبه افاد نادي الاسير الفلسطيني بان
قوات الاحتلال نفذت حمله اعتقالات صارت
سته مواطنين على الاقل في انحاء متفرقه
الغربيه
ابدا المتحدث باسم البنتاجون باترويدا قلق
وزاره الدفاع الامريكيه من التطورات
الجاريه في اسرائيل وفي لقاء خاص مع جزيره
دعا ريدر القاده الاسرائيليين للتواصل الى
تسويه تستعيد الهدوء
هذا وفادى ديوان رئيس الوزراء الاسرائيلي
بان رئيس الوزراء او عزا لاعضاء حكومته
بعدم التعقيب على تصريحات الرئيس الامريكي
بشان التعديلات القضائيه وبعد ان اعلن
رفضه للضغوط الامريكيه على حكومته قادر
نتنياهو الى التحالف بين الولايات المتحده
واسرائيل لا يتزعزع
نقلت الصحيفه الجنه عن مسؤول امريكيين
رفيع ان الضغط الامريكي لعب دورا مهما في
دفاع رئيس الوزراء الاسرائيلي الى التراجع
وتاجيل تشريع التعديلات القضائيه اضافت
الصحيفه ان حمله الضغط بدات منذ زياره
وزير الخارجيه الامريكيه الى اسرائيل في
فبراير الماضي كما نقلت
اسرائيلي ان الضغوط الامريكيه لا علاقه
لها بقرار نتنياهو تاجيله تشريعي
التعديلات القضائيه
صدمت مروحيتان تابعتان للجيش الامريكي
خلال مهمه خلال مهمه تدريبيه فوق ولايه
جنوب الولايات المتحده بحسب ما اعلن الجيش
الامريكي ولم يتضح الى الان ما اذا كانت
هناك اصابات ام لا
قال رئيس مجلس الدوله الصينيه لتشينج ان
اي نزاعات او فوضى في اسيا ستعصف بمستقبل
القارات كما قال نابجين تعارض العقوبات
الاحاديه والاصطفافات والانحياز او تكوين
تكتلات او نشوبه حرب بارده جديده
ان الصراع مع الغرب سيستمر لفتره طويله
جات ياكد رئيس هيئه الاركان الامريكيه
المشتركه انه من الصعب للغايه خوض حرب مع
روسيا والصين بشكل متزامن ميدانيه في
اوكرانيا قلم مؤسس مجموعه
من اجل بخموت دمرت الجيش الاوكراني رغم
الحاقها ضررا بالغا بقواته
شارك اكثر من 1700 عسكريا في مناوراتنا
عسكريه بقاعده امريكيه في جنوب المانيا
وشارك في هذه المناورات عسكريون من 18
بلدا وتزالت مع مناورات في استونيا ولا
ننطق باسم الجيش السوداني من القوات
المسلحه ملتزمه بالعمليه السياسيه وكانت
الجلسه الختاميه لورشه الاصلاح العسكري
والامنيه عقدت في الخرطوم في غياب رئيس
مجلس السياده ونائب رئيس مجلس السياده
وممثلي الجيش اشارت مصادر عسكريه سودانيه
للجزيره الى ان الجيش غير راض عن الورقه
التي قدمها ممثل قوات الدعم السريع لكونها
لم تتناول خطوات تؤدمج الدعم السريع داخل
الجيش وكان نائب رئيس مجلس السياده قال ان
الاصلاح لابد ان يشمل مؤسسه الدوله كافه
مشاهدينا انتهى هذا الموجز في امان الله
[موسيقى]